quand je vois ce monde qui s'annonce je
suis saisi de vertige et d'excitation un
vertige et une excitation conduire
sentir bien des hommes avant moi tenez
par exemple il y à peu près de 1500 ans
songer à un artisan à quelques
kilomètres d'athènes sur une de ces
collines que l'on voit en quittant la
capitale grecque en avion notre artisan
il fabrique par exemple des paniers
quand il veut échanger un panier contre
une bouteille de vin et bien il va voir
un producteur de vin qui habite à côté
de chez lui dans sa communauté et il
échange son panier contre sa bouteille
de vin et puis au loin ils voient se
construire le port du pirée
il sent que les choses ne seront plus
comme avant il est saisi d'excitation
parce que le port du pirée est une
magnifique nouveauté est en effet c'est
le début de la révolution de la
mondialisation mais en même temps la
construction du port du pirée
c'est un monde qui s'effondre et c'est
la fin de sa communauté puisque
désormais quand il voudra se procurer
une bouteille de vin ils les changera à
quelqu'un qui l'a produite de l'autre
côté de la mer méditerranée à des
centaines de kilomètres de chez lui
songez mille ans plus tard au moment de
la renaissance
vous pensez que le monde ait clos que
l'univers est finie que le ciel est un
toit que la terre est au milieu de
l'univers
et puis arrive la révolution
copernicienne
et là on vous explique que l'univers est
infinie chic et quelque chose qui est
très difficile en réalité à comprendre
on vous explique que la terre n'est pas
au milieu de l'univers mais qu'elle est
positionné là par hasard et on a pu
vérifier que la terre était ronde et non
pas plate et ça vraiment ça n'est pas
intuitif on vous explique que quand vous
allez par là au fond vous revenez par là
il ya eu beaucoup de dépression c'est
pas facile à concevoir au milieu du 19e
siècle
au moment de ce que l'on a appelé la
révolution industrielle
vous avez un naturaliste très connu à 20
km au sud de londres dans une ville qui
s'appelle donne il s'agit donc de
charles darwin qui vous explique que
vous ne venez pas de dieu mais vous
venez du chargeur il ya eu aussi
beaucoup d'incompréhension vous ne venez
pas d'en haut
vous venez d'en bas aujourd'hui c'est
quelque chose de cet ordre qui me saisit
quand je vois les implications de cette
vague d'innovation de cette nouvelle
révolution la révolution des haines
mais qui sait n pour nanotechnologies b
pour biotechnologies i pour tout ce qui
relève de l'information et le sait pour
les sciences cognitives dont relève par
exemple
l'intelligence artificielle et quand je
vois les implications que le sale
économique politique sociale des ntic
c'est vrai je suis saisi de vertige et
d'excitation d'excitation parce que ce
monde des ntic va être un monde
extraordinaire et il ya beaucoup de
choses que nous allons et mais dans ce
monde des ntic
moi je vais aimer la guérison des
cancers par exemple je vais aimer la fin
des embouteillages dans les villes grâce
à la voiture autonome
je vais aimer l'énergie décarbonée je
vais aimer la possibilité de construire
une usine dans ma chambre à coucher
grâce à l'imprimante 3d mais comprenez
bien une révolution de ce type
ce n'est pas seulement un monde qui
n'est c'est certes un monde qui n'est
mais c'est aussi un monde qui s'effondre
un monde qui disparaît et moi dans ce
monde qui disparaît il y avait aussi les
choses que j'aimais par exemple j'aime
les cartes routières
j'aime les cartes routières déplié sur
la table du salon pour essayer de
réfléchir à là où nous allons partir en
week end
j'aime les maisons et les immeubles
basse je vous déteste les tours que l'on
voit fleurir dans toutes les métropoles
du monde
et puis surtout j'aime les livres et
j'ai bien peur que le livre
disparaissent au profit du livre
électronique et la fin du livre pour moi
c'est le début d'une sorte de barbarie
est ce que ça fait de moi quelqu'un de
réactionnaire non je ne crois pas être
réactionnaire
ce serait vouloir conserver le passé
vouloir rester dans le passé mais moi ce
que je vous propose ce n'est pas de
rester dans le passé c'est bien d'entrer
dans l'avenir ce que je vous propose
c'est un progressisme conservateur
progressisme car nous voulons entrer
dans les ntic
mais conservateurs car il ya des choses
de notre civilisation que nous aimons et
que nous voulons conserver
alors attention attention aux fausses
idoles parce qu'il ya des choses que
nous ne pourrons pas ou peut-être pas
conservé je vais vous donner deux
exemples
premier exemple la famille d'amour
j'aime la famille d'amour je vis là
dedans
beaucoup d'entre nous aiment la famille
d'amour mais la famille d'amour est une
institution qui est né de la première
révolution industrielle
c'est une institution qui est né au fond
de la machine à vapeur et de l'exode
rural et je me dis ce qu'une révolution
industrielle a pu faire peut-être
malheureusement qu'une autre révolution
industrielle pour à le défaire et on en
voit d'ailleurs déjà les prémisses on
parle beaucoup de polygamie pour par
exemple le fait de vivre avec plusieurs
conjoints adultes au sein d'une même
famille on parle aussi des fermes à bb
le fait de pouvoir choisir les
caractéristiques génétiques de son futur
enfant
je ne suis honnêtement pas certain que
nous pourrons l'éviter je n'aime pas ça
mais je ne sais pas si nous pourrons
l'éviter deuxième exemple d'une
institution qu'ils pourraient
disparaître avec les nbc et pour le coup
je m'en réjouis
c'est la nation la nation est une
invention aussi récente du 19e siècle et
à l'ère des réseaux à l'ère de l'hyper
mondialisation peut être qu'enfin nous
allons
être non pas de là où nous avons été
enfanté mais nous allons être de là où
nous enfants ton ce serait la fin de la
nation au sens du 19e siècle
et pour le coup contrairement à la fin
de la famille d'amour je m'en réjouis
alors qu'allons nous garder quels sont
les éléments au fond qui ont passé
toutes les grandes transformations
technico économique est bien ce que nous
allons garder je les trouvais dans un
très vieux livre j'ai trouvé dans un
livre qui s'appelle la république un
livre de platon et dans ce livre
platon décrit ce qu'il appelle les
quatre vertus cardinales cardinal parce
que ce sont elles qui servent de pivot à
toutes les autres valeurs et c'est ça ce
que nous allons devoir garder ce sont
les quatre vertus cardinales la prudence
la tempérance le courage et la justice
la prudence s'oppose à la précaution la
précaution porte sur les fins la
prudence porte sur les moyens
la précaution vous dit ne fais pas la
prudence vous dis fais mais en fonction
de tes moyens fait prudemment la
précaution est une interdiction
la prudence est une régulation et nous
devons penser c'est régulation au niveau
politique la précaution vous dis non
nous n'entrons pas dans l'intelligence
artificielle trop dangereux la prudence
nous dit si bien sûr bien sûr nous
allons entrer dans l'intelligence
artificielle mais nous allons réguler
l'intelligence artificielle
intelligemment la tempérance la
tempérance vous dit tu dois rester
maîtres de ce qui arrive
la tempérance vous dit l'homme doit
rester maître de la machine
la tempérance vous dit si je suis
directeur d'hôpital et bien la génomique
ça va me servir à soigner les cancers
pas à proposer à de futurs parents de
choisir la couleur des yeux ou la
couleur des cheveux de leur futur enfant
le courage vous dit de changer tout de
suite
imaginez un libraire un libraire qui est
très bousculée par l'arrivée du livre en
ligne dont je parlais il y a un instant
le courage pour le libraire c'est de se
dire je vais transformer ma librairie
tout de suite je vais la transformer
pour en faire un lieu de culture je vais
la transformer pour en faire un lieu où
les gens viendront boire un thé ou un
café pour parler des nouveautés dans le
domaine musical dans le domaine
littéraire je vais en faire un lieu dans
lequel les gens vont payer pour venir
voir des expositions
ça c'est le courage de changer et le
courage ne se conjugue pas le courage
c'est par définition tout de suite et
puis quatrième vertus cardinales
bien évidemment la justice la justice
c'est l'idée selon laquelle nous devons
collectivement fournir une solution à
notre libraire notre libraire qui est
menacé de disparaître
que devons-nous lui dire nous devons lui
apporter des solutions nous devons lui
apporter des solutions en termes de
redistribution
nous devons lui apporter des solutions
en termes d'entrepreneuriat nous devons
lui apporter des solutions en termes de
formation et finalement la justice c'est
l'idée selon laquelle les ntic doivent
profiter à l'ensemble de la population
et pas simplement à certains ce que je
vous propose ce progressisme
conservateur que je vous propose ce
n'est pas un slogan c'est une façon de
vivre et c'est une façon d'agir
par exemple certains d'entre vous ont
des enfants
le progressisme conservateurs vous dis
oui
laissez un ipad dans les mains de vos
enfants mais apprenez leur les vertus
classique
oui qu'on apprenne aux enfants
le code très bien mais s'il vous plaît
qu'on continue de le renseigner le grec
et le latin le progressisme
conservateurs ont dit oui tu peux
laisser tes enfants jouer aux jeux vidéo
mais feller aussi écouter vivaldi ça
n'est pas être passéiste c'est être
réaliste
merci